hey guys right here John here just moved
into a new place now it's trying to play
catch up on some videos here and one
thing that's very I'm gonna have a talk
to mom for a week how Ben Affleck left
the Batman and now Matt Reeves was in
talks but then as of today just just
directing right yeah I didn't miss a
thing where he just quit the project in
charge oh yeah Ben Affleck left entirely
what no no there's no rumor going around
that Ben Ali was gonna leave like he's
trying to buy don't believe that he just
needed to leave one meeting to go to
happy world are you trying to get out a
little early wbs I said oh no I have to
get attention and that reads the top
contender and they were going to
negotiations from matt reeves ultimately
decided not to do it no one really knows
why visual effects he's still working on
posts for four awards plan of the age so
it makes sense that he wouldn't want to
be that guy who's like oh I got a
half-assed this movie to work on the
Babbage I'll work on one and sand that
marriage would have been a cool choice
what we thought we'd take this video
today to give a couple of suggestions of
our own honestly i think matt reeves
would have been a fine choice he doesn't
have a distinct visual flair to me where
I'm like Matt reeves's voice is what
this movie needs and I think of Batman
you should get somebody with a more
distinct voice not just someone is going
to turn her pretty good blockbuster way
before I move on to her choices Mary's
is an amazing director he can direct but
he doesn't he's not distinct to me that
way I don't want him a tree style I just
think a plan of the age but we don't
clover I don't feel like we need a
specific director style to go along with
this that's what's great about Mallory
says he has a variety of styles like you
see a film like Cloverfield which was
awesome and then you feel like dawn of
the Planet of the Apes which was a
sequel to and already built in franchise
and he really made it his own and one of
the best planet of the apes film yeah
another thing he's a bad directed by any
stretch for whatever reason there's
something that's not i will get anyone
could it'd enix like me know what I
heard that yeah it give me that I'm sure
matt reeves would do a good job I want
I'm saying like I
he would turn out a good movie with some
some nice flourishes but he doesn't go
oh yeah like yeah sounds like a sensible
choice I'll give you that I'll give you
that I think he's a great director but
it wasn't only minor battery as I was
like that's laughing I didn't like you
he's got so anyway we'll give our
thought on who we think could be a great
director for the bad man I have a couple
of choices that to people who I think
would be very very good choices my first
one's a little bit more obvious one that
I think a lot of people have suggested
he was supposed to do man of steel part
to that Judge Christopher Reeve George
George arif George Miller god damn i
need my caffeine George Reed plays
everything every video today as we gonna
need my caffeine again remember he said
George Miller you know he did all the
Mad Max phones mad max fury road I'm not
super familiar with George Miller's work
outside of mad men shoes they've paid to
have any happy feet yeah he brought
something unique to the Mad Max world
and then he comes back as like decades
later with fury road and brought back
hold me visceral kind of look and style
with amazing action set pieces and he's
all about practical I feel like George
Miller he would do a really good job and
I feel like bringing especially when
thinking not just about Batman but about
whatever other villains are bringing
kind of a craziness to the Gotham world
like I feel like he could bring Gotham
to what yeah and I think George Miller
could balance the things that you want
out of this movie and avoid something
like a BBS debacle like he can bring the
cool gritty serious stuff that you want
he can do a lot at least as far as the
Mad Max movie show us you know with
maybe not as much dialogue and a lot of
body language and like there's a lot in
his repertoire that he could get he's
good everywhere as good at working was
like kind of creepy characters it was
just a different kind of vibe overall
I'd say that he could bring Gotham to
life in a brand-new way definitely and
he can do a world he can do stunts he
have action like he can do it I think
it's a great because then that man's
already defined it like how he's been
defined BBS and what were seen in
Justice League and stuff yeah we'll see
a different side of that man in the solo
film but in terms of building the whole
world of Gotham and the other bill into
the row gallery Georgian I think would
be a great choice the other
director of mine who you think would be
a good chew it you know I kind of had a
hard time with this because it's hard to
think of it's really hard to think of
like an you need to make the right
choice I feeling for Batman I don't have
like a great I just wrote a couple names
basically I know a lot of people drop
Darren Aronofsky's name over the years
and well I don't necessarily want to see
him go do a big DC EU movie I think he
could do it because he is good at making
those movies about people who are
unhealthily obsessed with the driving
force of their life and that's something
you can apply Batman he's got a knack
for strange and creepy imagery also and
he's done big budget before well I feel
like the best Batman story like my
favorite Batman phone with the dark
knight was the best Batman story where I
feel like I really got to know that man
was Batman Begins a lot of it was
inspired by Batman year one and darren
aronofsky he was trying to do a Batman
you were one movie for quite a while
totally yeah before like they redid with
no one films and stuff he was trying to
a Batman year one movie and he was even
supposed to do uh the wolverine movie
that James Mengel took over eventually
if he could come in and and so I could
write the ship for DC that would be cool
yeah I'm not sure Darren ops ii would
agree to do it because he the reason he
left Wolverine was because he wanted
spent on his family he saw they're doing
a movies on this caliber would take away
from sounds like a year yeah which makes
you wonder how long no it took
confessing wasn't no one from no small
undertaking I think they're not enough
he could bring great care of her life I
feel like he could bring that he's great
at exploring dark themes and characters
there's no dark again yeah you know how
to watch people deteriorate like they
are there are elements of body horror
and they're very sort of uncomfortable
and there is always that element of
obsession like all of this movie out an
obsession see and I feel like Batman and
you're talking about the deterioration
one thing I thought was fascinating me
with in terms of the Batman myth oh it's
how like the villains and peep in like
that I begins like even hints that it
were the world kind of used Batman like
oh it is monsters yeah you've been bad
you know good and I feel like he could
bring the monster out of Bruce Wayne
yeah and he could also bring the debate
out of Bruce Wayne because of the dark
life that him and we see different
balances of Bruce Wayne vs Batman in
these movies his life as Batman has got
to be a challenging thing with as many
things as we complain about as fans now
like I feel like you could address a lot
of those in an interesting way and still
get all your candy you know still have
your cool villains and you cool fights
in a lab near your tie in another choice
to be carrot lemon who did haha raise
them because I mean think of it like
this Batman Begins and in the dark and I
were directed by the same director and a
lot of people kind of view the rate one
and two in the same formula of the dark
knight of how that went like the first
one was really fun really cool and
awesome and brought like Batman digas
rub em into a new caliber and the raid
brought action films to a new caliber
and then Dark Knight comes along epic
that's a crime saga and then in the rate
he would think it's a crime Sade yeah I
feel like this guy has proven that he
can adapt to to doing more than just
cool action scenes he can deliver great
intense emotional scene and character
and suspense and on top of that when I
saw the fight scene that everyone raved
about mbbs like one of the few moments
that are like objectively good in BBS
and that fight kinda remind me a little
bit of raid style and I think I think
that was something I think i mighta
heard that somewhere where that was a
source of inspiration for the kind of
fighting I feel like okay it's the one
thing that got right was that man
fighting yeah and his action style why
not get you know Gareth Evans come in
and help out with hansung the action
experience more because right now with
DC really needs is a great film yes but
if they can't get a great film at least
get a solid like everyone thinks it's a
good film overall and I feel like Gareth
Evans can do that by really capitalizing
on like the awesome action sequence in
terms of the martial arts fighting and
stuff because the villain that they
wrote was Deathstroke the Deathstroke is
a martial artist okay so if you're going
to have Batman and destro going
toe-to-toe like Gareth Evans to me is
the ultimate choice see if it was like
the Joker and Batman I'd be like George
Miller do that yeah but if it's like
Deathstroke and Batman
yeah did you hear that yeah yeah i
render anyway you sold me yeah and on
that yeah I came up with a nobody just
came to mind I thought of this night I
came up with a few list of potential
ones one that stood out to me more and
more as I thought about it was a damn
trachtenberg who did 10 Cloverfield Lane
because like that movie and it might be
a weird call that I'm feeling like
you're doing a new Batman movie this guy
leaves with 10 Cloverfield Lane that is
his to my understanding i believe his
first feature length film so that's a
concern but that movie has both like
this sort of dready taught character
stuff and when it finally gets to the
sci-fi there's some you know sighs by
action e stuff too and i think that if
you want to get somebody new because i
thought it like a davidson sure Batman
movie would be cool and don't think
it'll ever ever happen happen Ellie is
unrealistic or like I thought I even
which house key action movie could be a
Batman movie could be a cool thing but
this guy is maybe they don't want to
throw down on quite a cloudy director
who's gonna be like I get a say in all
this you know and also who might bring
some bigger I thought I thought damn
tractor where it might be a good idea
also the spirit brothers to go to
daybreakers I think that can be cool cuz
s got a Gotham me just after midnight
vibe yeah I me how in that movie and
they can handle Syfy they can handle
action they can handle humor true oh I
know it was the last one I thought about
it could be a good idea was bradford
president maybe because he's done big
action he's done like Mission Possible
and maybe look so light yeah well maybe
this would be a good chance for him to
do something a bit darker because it
comes out of animation you know he's got
to be familiar with with comics and
stuff like that and the cartoons to draw
from I feel like he'd be good for like
Wonder Woman or a Green Lantern I don't
know about Batman yeah he's not here i
would go automatically yeah and they
just come to mind that it didn't float
out of my mind you know sort of like
that's dumb kind of way it was like huh
maybe like it would be a question mark
for sure i would be interested in seeing
that I feel like you we need to do like
a superhero his Batman Athena day is
human he's still super hero but he's
easy to human being I feel like you need
to take on like I think you look great
too
man movie that is yeah anything Bradbury
could do that next nighter should have
done that and I'm revirginized Ibraham
even with a more like character-driven
that guy's your guy oh yeah those are
our choices for side I guess if we had
our like top three choices it seems like
it would go George Miller's no it's
darren aronofsky or Gareth Evans ya feel
like those are be our top three choices
where your guys's you know people you
wouldn't mind seeing direct the Batman
films and the pc is watching this pay
attention comment subscribe to the real
rejects John's reason to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram as a social media
manager of blue house from the real
rejects right and shout out to George
Clooney who has not had a hit that dense
Batman sabaton it sucks his careers just
gone down home yeah what's he done land
he hasn't done any but Joel Schumacher's
can't applaud dude especially I've we
remember 23 like ah there's no it's
gonna wire yeah weird how George's went
down and so it's just Schumacher tied
everything about your affair telling us
on your Schumacher but yeah